will Kanye make a comeback or is this a
downfall that's going to be hard to
recover from that's going to take a few
years to come back I'll be very clear
unless his music
lives up to the standards that he's
already put out there I do not think so
because people aren't trying to hear
Kanye for his political views or his
business ideas you know there's a famous
saying I miss the old Kanye I miss the
people actually miss the old Kanye
because of his music not because of his
ideology so no
you think you think he's done done
what do you think oh I think he really
showed his true colors I mean I think
this I said this just I think this is
absolute cowardice he said stupid [ __ ]
for 10 years he's gotten backlash for
since Trump ran he wore the freaking
Mega hat and now all of a sudden he
loses to 2 billion he loses his
endorsements Etc et cetera et cetera now
it's oh my God I'm so sorry America's
racist uh George Floyd
died from a knee on the neck um you know
just begging for forgiveness for his two
or two billion back and granted I've
never lost 2 billion in a day but no I I
think he showed his true colors and I
don't think he makes a comeback that's
it you think it's done though I think I
think why I think he showed his fans
like the people that follow him now not
for music but outside that I think he
showed it exactly Kevin Spacey ever
comes back
and becomes Kevin Spacey without us
looking at him the way we looked at him
I think so but I think it's two
different things music is inherently fad
based right and trend-based whereas an
actor and actress can come back as an as
an older version of themselves
particularly males yeah not not females
as much because once you're 40 in
Hollywood don't attack me here you're
80. I'm not gonna attack no seriously
once you're 40 is a female you're 80.
but can Kevin Spacey come back I mean
look at what I like to look at Michael
Keaton he didn't have like a crisis but
let's just take a look he had this lull
where his career was gone and all of a
sudden he's he came back and there was
things in his career well look that's
the way Hollywood works because acting
is different than music music is fad
based I think it's really hard for uh
Kanye to come back what do you think
about it you know for me here's here's
what we're learning who you can call out
and who you cannot call out like there
there is there are certain people in the
room you can insult and certain people
cannot insult uh you're you're really
seeing who is one of the most powerful
communities in America that if you even
get close to insulting or touching what
the consequences could be and he's
feeling it right now especially the way
that he did it because you can you can
insult whites as much as you want you're
not going to get in trouble that's just
the truth of it you can people say stuff
about the white community and they
butcher them around and trash them and
say whatever they want pretty much you
can pretty much say everything you want
no one says anything God forbid
you say certain things about certain
communities oh
you're permanently done what he's saying
is not you know people have said it on
the opposite side I can if I really
wanted to do a case study I can go on
the opposite side and see how many
people have said stuff about you know uh
oh you you have to be careful saying
stuff about Muslims but you can say
whatever you want about Christians you
have to be careful about what you say
about blacks but you can say whatever
you want about white you have to be
careful saying whatever you want about
Jews but you can say whatever this is
this is also a slippery slope for me now
obviously what he said and the way he
said it death con what do you say death
content what are you doing but but a lot
of it for me comes from a standpoint of
oh my gosh who is really running this
country to protect those few that we
cannot touch that that's the one part
that that becomes a bit of a slippery
slope on uh who you can call out and who
you cannot call out and we we just
learned it this this is known as one of
the greatest artists few things that I
don't like about what he does like
posting text messages you get from
people on your Instagram back to back to
back to back to back to back to back
that's a character flaw can't do that
what are you doing posting text messages
you're getting from people on yours you
go to his Instagram profile it's all
text why are you doing that do you know
that's permanent
do you know what I'm saying when I say
that permanent if you delete it yeah
that's permanent yeah that's Evan
permanent like permanently
you're not going to be texted by people
you have to you can't even go on Signal
like it's you there's certain behavior
that to me is not has nothing to do with
this to me it has to do with a complete
different thing that is um
challenges you go through you've got to
be very who's what what real qualified
one like a the kind of wife that he
wants who's going to want to be with a
guy like him today knowing that at any
point he can put your business on blast
publicly and by the way the same goes
with the Kardashians what guy a real
real not not if you want to marry a
celebrity because you have to stay
within the celebrity world I get it like
who's Kim gonna date next and marry
let's face it there's odds out there for
this by the way yeah yeah so I I saw
that you know Vance is uh what's his
name Vance Jones some reason is the top
of the list yeah but but the point being
who's she gonna end up with she can only
be with a power player she's not going
to end up with it like Pete Davidson's
like yeah okay good you had fun six
months you really messed with you know
uh mess with Kanye who did Pete date
that the ex killed himself or committed
suicide Mac Miller Mac Miller right so
the pizza's also a dark character he's
also guys Ariana Grande with Mac Miller
yeah I'm sorry Ariana Grande I'm not I'm
not a follower who she was engaged to
Pete Davidson that's where yeah so Stars
so I mean look there's a lot of people
involved in a situation like this but to
me it's more about character than who
you have to go back like hey JLo you
your brand was very good when you were
Ben Affleck those are the conversations
in this world so are you really gonna be
with somebody that you're laying next to
in bed wanting to have a conversation
how was your day or is it really did you
see my Q score went up after we got
married three months ago what a [ __ ]
conversation to have at night laying
next to a person but that's the reality
but the point is what a waste of a life
what a waste of a life what a waste of a
life favorite parts of my life are
conversations relationships moments
experiences that are re real raw genuine
moments you're going through troubles we
sit down we have a conversation you're
in tears you're opening up I'm talking
to you this is between us that's a bond
right you're going through a challenge
no one knows about it we're sharing that
that's life this this is [ __ ] this
is just
and and I hope people watching these
younger Generations not sitting there
saying man I really want to be in this
kind of mess it's a completely different
life anyway so that's my opinions I just
think certain people have little too
much power today you can't talk about
them it scares the crap out back to your
initial question do you think Kanye
makes a comeback I think he does I think
he does but I think it's going to take
four to five years I think it's going to
take a while I think it's gonna take a
while this is America you have to
realize one thing about America
America is very annoying with stars and
they want to see them fall they want to
see them fall but but they love
Redemption and comebacks this is America
man this is America you know like the
whole concept of the church what's the
church if you're like a born-again type
of thing if you're born again all your
sins are forgiven America if it was a
religion it's a similar feeling because
we will judge you all the way to the end
but man when you fall
year later two years later we can't wait
for you to come back and a changed human
being hopefully and you got new thing
that we can learn from you and redeem
yourself hopefully I don't know if it's
going to happen problem though Pat I
think is that he made everybody mad like
so he made the people initially he made
the comments and he made a whole bunch
of people mad yeah he's anti-semitic
he's that then he apologizes and now he
makes a whole bunch of other people now
that's what they're saying oh why are
you capable but that's character right
that's a character flaw when you do that
that you said something earlier you said
every time I open my mouth I offend half
so what he did is he opened his mouth
and he opened his mouth right yeah right
so he offended 100 what are you doing
bro take a position at least at least I
respect AOC because she takes a position
you took a position go for it so now
when you're flip-flopping right John
Kerry lost the election years ago
because he flip-flopped two audiences
gave two different messages America
doesn't like flip-floppers one more
thing with Kanye I agree whether it's
the politics whether it's your your
brand your personality you have to have
a base we all know It's gotta play to
your base your base your base so who's
Kanye's base what does he actually care
about obviously he cares a lot about his
people black people like he says this I
got to take care of my people I gotta
help my people is there anything that
his people are not down with more than
Mega
okay like
straight up just look at the like black
people don't feel Maga I actually I
disagree for 90 that's great
um but his black people aren't feeling
Mago disagree or not I'm letting you
know that ain't that's the case secondly
when you go White lives matter you think
black people are down with that I'm
saying as a group no so he's he's doing
things and then black people I think for
the most part agree that George Floyd
may have had uh fentanyl in his system
but he died because someone an officer's
knee was on the back of their neck
there's not a lot of harder guys in the
hip-hop world than Kevin Gates have you
heard what he said or Ice Cube remember
what Ice Cube said yeah you have to go
go with Kevin Gates though go with Kevin
Gates first of all I love Kevin Gates
and you know some of the stuff that he
says just like the benefit of being a
street guy and an artist where you've
partied with all these guys and then
you're like wait you the only pieces the
only people who give me a hard time with
my success as my own people he says I've
never had a white person that's unhappy
for My Success so that conversation is
being had and it needs to be had so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]